in a few of the previous videos I've
mentioned the electron transport chain
without really talking too much about it
in this video I want to introduce it a
little bit so the purpose of the
electron transport chain really is to
make lots of ATP lots of energy so the
electron transport chain is actually
basically the reason it's a chain is
it's a series of redox reactions ending
with taking oxygen and actually turning
it into water so we're taking oxygen to
water we're adding some hydrogen's here
lowering the number of bonds to oxygen
we're actually reducing rises as a
reducing reaction we're reducing oxygen
to water and because the series of redox
reactions actually ends with oxygen
being turned to water this is considered
an aerobic process right because oxygen
is actually required in this chain of
redox reactions more specifically this
the purpose of the electron transport
chain is to reoxidized all the nad ages
and fadh2 until this point whether it
was in glycolysis or the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex or the TCA cycle
any any DHS and fadh2 s that we made
will be reoxidized back into the nad
plusses and fa d's respectively now
where is the electron transport chain
it's somewhere in the mitochondria but
specifically where in the mitochondria
is it along the inner membrane now which
I'll talk about in just a second when I
get to this diagram the electron
transport chain like I mentioned is a
series of redox reactions ending with
going from oxygen to water now that
those that series of redox reactions is
coupled to the phosphorylation of ATP to
yield ATP right so we because we want to
make ATP and electron transport chain so
what we do that is a bunch of different
redox reactions is is coupled to the
phosphorylation of adp to ATP now if you
recall ATP phosphorylating adp to or to
make an or
is that Delta G going to be positive or
negative this is going to be a positive
Delta G because we're making the energy
right so that's going to be energy is
going to be required so if this process
if taking ADP and phosphate leading it
to ATP is an endergonic process and it's
coupled to this series of redox
reactions we would expect this series of
redox reactions to be what we would
expect this series of redox reactions to
be exergonic right because they need to
be coupled to the fot this
phosphorylation right so they need to be
releasing energy that we can use to
power the production of ATP excuse me
so how exactly does that even happen
well the electron transport chain
basically what it's supposed to do is
supposed to build up an electrochemical
gradient with a high pH or shooting me a
hike h+ concentration which is a low pH
a high H+ concentration at a low pH in
the inter membrane space and a low H+
concentration which would be a high pH
in the mitochondrial matrix so now what
are these things that's brings me to
this diagram here I'll talk about how
this diagram and these words here deal
with this idea of an electrochemical
gradient in case you'd already don't
already know the anatomy of a
mitochondrion which is it an organelle
via known as the energy powerhouse of a
sell this thing labeled a here is the
outer membrane of the mitochondria I'm
just going to abbreviate mitochondrial
as just my toe
now the mitochondrion right has two
membranes okay so as its outer membrane
here and this inner membrane here that's
actually folded a bunch here this is the
inner mitochondrial membrane and that is
actually the membrane where we have
that's where the electron transport
chain is right
we mentioned that the electron transport
chain exists along the inner membrane of
the mitochondrion so the electron
transport chain all of its little
protein complex as well top which I'll
talk about in the next video they're
going to be along this membrane here
this inner membrane
now C and D are actually pointing to
different sort of spaces so C is the
space between the outer membrane and the
inner membrane so that is the inter
membrane space so that inter membrane
space is a space between two membranes
if you think about what international
flight is the international flight is
flight between countries right so this
space is between the two membranes and D
of course is the mitochondrial matrix
which is just a space that is bound by
the inner membrane which is where of
course the the TCA cycle occurs and the
pyruvate dehydrogenase step occurs now I
mentioned this idea of building an
electrochemical gradient with a high H+
concentration in the intermembrane space
and a low h+ concentration in the
mitochondrial matrix so what this
electron transport chain is basically
going to do is that there's gonna be a
bunch of redox reactions and through
these redox reactions that are being
extra gonig that that energy that that
energy released is going to be used to
build up H+ out high H+ concentration
out here in this intermembrane space
whereas we're gonna have a very low
concentration of h+ is inside the matrix
so we have a bunch of h+ is out here in
the intermembrane space and we're going
to build up an electrochemical gradient
a chemical gradient because we're gonna
have a lot of a lot more of something on
on one side of a membrane than the other
and because we have a lot of a a lot of
these protons on one side of the
membrane there's also an electrical
gradient a voltage gradient because with
these these H pluses they're charged
right these this plus is a positive
charge we're gonna have a positive
charge on the in the intermembrane space
and a relatively negative charge in
in the mitochondrial matrix as far as
voltage the the the electrical potential
difference so I'll talk more about that
in later videos but what we needed to
understand in about this about the
electron transport chain is that because
it's a series of redox reactions we need
to understand these this idea of
reduction potentials and the reason why
is because we want to know where the
electrons are going because if there's a
bunch of redox reactions that means
there's loss of electrons gain of
electrons and we want to know where
these electrons are going
that's where reduction potentials come
in so reduction potentials essentially
what they do is if you know the
reduction potentials value you basically
know how good or bad an electron donor
or acceptor something is if it is here
so if you have a low or very negative
reduction potential that means that that
that particular species would that
you're concerned with does not want to
be reduced low reduction it does not
want to be reduced so what is reduction
reduction is the gain of electrons so if
something has a low reduction potential
it doesn't want to be reduced it does
not want to gain electrons so instead
what it would rather do is it would
rather give electrons away right which
would be oxidized right it would want to
be oxidized so if it doesn't want to
gain the electrons and would much prefer
to give them away it would be considered
a better donor if something you know has
a relatively low reduction potential
it's going to be a better donor so
whereas a a high or very positive
reduction potential indicates that that
thing was is wants to be reduced high
reduction it wants to be reduced it does
want to be reduced if it does want to be
reduced it wants to gain electrons so it
will accept electrons from something
else now this would be a better acceptor
well we know that the electron transport
chain as we set up here we said that
a series of redox reactions ending with
oxygen being reduced to water so if
oxygen wants to be reduced but we expect
its reduction potential to be like well
if it wants to be reduced and it's
actually the last thing in the chain
that's reduced it's going to be a very
good acceptor right it's gaining those
electrons so oxygen is a very very good
example of something that would have a
high reduction potential it's actually
it's reduction potential is 0.88 1/6
volts which is would basically describes
a spontaneous reaction that oxygen will
definitely willingly accept electrons
from something else that has a a lower
reduction potential which is which is
something I was trying to get over here
so if something does not want to gain
electrons it would rather give them away
it's going to be a donor what would we
expect to be a good donor here scroll
back up briefly so we said that we're
oxidizing nadh and fadh2 s back to nad
plus and F ad so those things are going
to be oxidized if they're being oxidized
they're going to they don't want to gain
they're not gaining electrons they're
losing them right so they're giving up
their electrons therefore they're better
donors and they would have low reduction
potentials so NADH actually is a good
example of a good donor and its
production potential is negative 0.32
zero volts now to be specific a
reduction potential is based on this
idea of something being reduced so nad
nad plus would would get reduced rather
to nad NADH so that process has a
negative reduction potential and that
basically means that it's non
spontaneous so it would rather not gain
electrons instead it wants to give them
up so it is a better donor essentially
what you do what do you really need to
know about all this nonsense here is
that when it comes to reduction
potentials low reduction potentials
means it wants to give up its electrons
high reduction potentials means it wants
to accept those electrons so what if you
know that two different species have two
different reduction
Scholz you should know that the
electrons will throw from the low
reduction potential to the high
reduction potential so in this case if
we're going from the if NADH and O 2 are
near each other then NADH is going to
donate its electrons to O which makes
sense because NADH has the lower or -
potential and OH - has the higher one so
it's very very important to keep this
idea of reduction potentials in myelin
making about the electron transport
chain because there's a bunch of
different things involved in the
electron transport chain and they all
have different reduction potentials so
if I presented it to you the question
which of which of these different things
has a higher or lower reduction
potential well knowing at what point it
comes down in the chain and let's try on
transport chain you should be able to
judge which should have the higher
vertex potential which would have the
lower reduction potential
anyway I'll get to two more details
about that in the next video thanks for
watching